So for this quiz, the question is, given the variables
that are defined here, and you'll see the variables already defined
in the code in your web browser. Your goal is
to write Python code that prints out the distance, in meters,
that light travels in one processor cycle. Do the first
variable as speed of light, and we've assigned to the variable
speed_of_light the number of meters that light travels in a
second. It might be hard to remember that. So we also
have a comment there. We haven't used comments yet but they're
a very useful thing to add to our programs. We can write
a comment by starting with a hash symbol, that's usually the
Shift+3 on most keyboards. Everything from the hash to the end of
the line is a comment. That means it's ignored by the
Python interpreter, but it's useful for the programmer to be able to
see it. So we'll have a comment here that says that's
meters per second. We can put anything we want in our comments.
They are not interpreted by the Python interpreter. But it's a
good idea to have comments that are helpful for us to remember
what we did if we need to go back to the
code a few months from now and understand it. It's also a
good idea if someone else is reading the code, the comments
will help them understand it. So
the second variable, we'll call cycles_per_second,
and we'll give that the value 2 billion 700 million. And
I'm going to give it a decimal point so when Python does division,
we'll get exact results. And we'll also give a
comment for this one to indicate that this is the
2.7 Gigahertz speed that the processor in my computer
has. So now, given those two variable definitions, your goal
is to write some Python code that prints out
the distance, in meters, that light travels in one processor
cycle. And we can compute that by dividing the
speed of light by the number of cycles per second.